TAKE THEIR SEATS.
HELLO
EVERYONE WELCOME TO THE
CONVENING OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SESSION OF THE
SENATE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MADAM PRESIDENT PRO
TEM THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR OF
INVITING ME TO PRESIDE TODAY
AND FOR YOUR COURAGEOUS
LEADERSHIP DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. MADAM
SECRETARY ERICA CONTRARIES
THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR SERVICE
HERE TODAY. IT IS WONDERFUL TO
SEE SO MANY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES BACK TOGETHER AFTER
MANY MONTHS APART AND EVEN
THOUGH WE CAN ONLY SEE THE TOP
HALF OF EACH OTHER'S FACES OUR
OLD COLLEAGUES ARE IMMEDIATELY
RECOGNIZABLE TO ONE ANOTHER. TO
ALL THE NEW MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
ELECTION AND WELCOME TO YOUR
NEW OFFICE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS. AND TO ALL THOSE
PARTICIPATING FROM HOME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU IN PERSON
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. ABOUT
ELEVEN YEARS AGO JUST BEFORE I
WAS SWORN IN AS UNITED STATES
AMBASSADOR. I WAS VISITING THE
OPS CENTER IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S MAIN BUILDING IN
WASHINGTON DC. THE OPS CENTER
SHARPER OPERATIONS CENTER. IS A
WINDOW LIST SERIES OF ROOMS
WHERE STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICERS
ARE ON DUTY TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY MONITORING GLOBAL EVENTS IN
REAL TIME. HURRICANES WARS
MILITARY FLARE UPS AIRPLANE
CRASHES REFUGEE MIGRATIONS IT'S
THE OPS CENTER JOB TO KEEP AN
EYE OUT FOR BIG SUDDEN
PROBLEMS. AND THEN ALERT THE
RIGHT PEOPLE WHEN THEY HAPPEN.
AS I LOOKED AROUND THE CENTRAL
ROOM I NOTICED A LARGE WHITE
BOARD WE'RE IN GIANT LETTERS
SOMEONE HAD WRITTEN H. ONE N.
ONE. H. ONE N. ONE ALSO CALLED
THE SWINE FLU WAS GENETICALLY
THE CLOSEST STRAIN OF FLU TO
THE NINETEEN EIGHTEEN PANDEMIC
THAT THE WORLD HAD SEEN SINCE.
THE CDC NOW ESTIMATES THAT
SIXTY MILLION AMERICANS ABOUT
ONE IN FIVE OF US WERE INFECTED
WITH THE H. ONE AND ONE. ON THE
DAY I STOOD IN THE OP CENTER
PEOPLE WERE REALLY WORRIED HOW
BAD WOULD IT BE HOUSE SICK
WOULD PEOPLE GET HOW FAST WITH
THE VIRUS SPREAD. FORTUNATELY
WE WOULD SOON DISCOVER THAT THE
H. ONE N. ONE VIRUS WELL HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS AND DIFFICULT TO
CONTAIN. DIDN'T MAKE PEOPLE
VERY SICK AND WITH LESS DEADLY
THAN THE FLU. THE WORLD GOT
LUCKY. SEVERAL YEARS LATER IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE LARGEST
OUTBREAK OF THE EBOLA VIRUS
OCCURRED IN WEST AFRICA. THIS
TIME THE VIRUS WAS EXTREMELY
DEADLY AN AVERAGE OF 50% OF
THOSE WHO CONTRACTED EBOLA DIED
BUT UNLIKE H. ONE N. ONE EBOLA
IS FAR LESS CONTAGIOUS IT'S
HARDER TO CATCH REQUIRING VERY
CLOSE PHYSICAL CONTACT TO
SPREAD. WE JUST HEALTH WORKERS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING
FROM THE UNITED STATES
MOBILIZED AND WERE ABLE TO
CONTAIN THE DISEASE AND
MINIMIZE THE SPREAD. JUST
ELEVEN CASES AVAILABLE LAST
MADE IT TO THE US. AGAIN THE
WORLD GOT LUCKY. I'M SHARING
THIS WITH YOU TODAY BECAUSE THE
SOMEONE WHO SERVED AS A SENIOR
US GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE KNEW THE DAY
WOULD COME WHEN THE WORLD
EXPERIENCED A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT WOULD BE BOTH VERY LETHAL
AND HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS. WE ALSO
KNEW THAT THERE WAS NO WAY TO
BE FULLY PREPARED AND TELL WHAT
HAPPENED. IN THIS CONTEXT I AM
VERY PROUD OF CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN.
FROM THE BEGINNING WE BELIEVE
THE SCIENCE WE HAD FAITH IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS WE HAD
THE COURAGE TO ISSUE THE FIRST
STATE WIDE STAY AT HOME ORDER
IN THE COUNTRY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
AND CONTINUE TO HAVE FAITH IN
THEIR GOVERNMENT. AND ARE DOING
THEIR PART TO STOP THE SPREAD.
TODAY WE MOURN THE TRAGIC LOSS
OF TWENTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
AND GRIEVE WITH THE FAMILIES OF
THOSE LOST BUT WE SHOULD NOTE
THAT WITHOUT THE SWIFT DECISIVE
RESPONSE FROM GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AND THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
THE SITUATION WOULD HAVE BEEN
FAR WORSE. AS YOU ALL KNOW WE
ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF ANOTHER
SPIKE IN COVERT NINETEEN CASES
WITH THE RECORD THIRTY THOUSAND
NEW CASES YESTERDAY. HEALTH
CARE WORKERS ARE BRACING FOR
MORE HOSPITALIZATIONS
BUSINESSES ARE BRACING FOR A
NEW ROUND OF CLOSURES. BUT THIS
TIME THERE IS A LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL VACCINES ARE
ON THEIR WAY AND AS WE PREPARE
FOR ANOTHER DIFFICULT FEW WEEKS
IT IS GOOD TO KNOW THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND OUR STATE HEALTH
OFFICIALS. ARE HARD AT WORK
PLANNING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
VACCINES FIRST AND FOREMOST TO
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS THEN TO
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THEN TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE. AS WE OPEN THE
SENATE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO LEGISLATIVE SESSION THE
WORK OF THIS BODY IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. TEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE FILED
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT SINCE MARCH
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE MANY
BUSINESSES HAVE SHUTTERED WHILE
OTHERS HANG ON BY A THREAD.
WITH SCHOOLS CLOSED MOST OF OUR
CHILDREN WLL MISS AN ENTIRE
YEAR IN PERSON LEARNING. AND
JUST AS THE CHALLENGES BROUGHT
ON BY COVERT NINETEEN AWAIT
YOUR ACTION SO DO PERSISTENT
PROBLEMS THAT OUR STATE HAS
STRUGGLED WITH FOR YEARS
HOUSING SHORTAGES AND
HOMELESSNESS WILDFIRES INCOME
INEQUALITY CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO
MANY OTHERS. IT'S A LOT BUT YOU
ARE UP TO IT. TODAY AS IT
HAPPENS IS DECEMBER SEVENTH A
DAY THAT WILL LIVE IN INFAMY
FOR SEVENTY YEARS AGO US NAVAL
FORCES WERE ATTACKED AT PEARL
HARBOR. AS WE REMEMBER THE
VETERANS OF THE SECOND WORLD
WAR AND THE VETERANS OF ALL OUR
MILITARY ENGAGEMENTS LET US
ALSO DRAW FROM THE COURAGE AND
RESILIENCE THAT THEY HAD. WITH
HARD WORK PERSISTENCE COMMON
PURPOSE AND ROBUST DEBATE LET'S
SET THE BEST POSSIBLE EXAMPLE
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WE PROUDLY
SERVE. EVEN WITH OUR OWN SHORT
COMINGS AND HUMAN IMPERFECTIONS.
FINALLY IT LET ME JUST NOTE
THAT VERY SOON WE WILL HAVE A
NEW GOVERNMENT IN WASHINGTON DC
A NEW PRESIDENT AND JOE BIDEN
AT THE VERY FIRST WOMAN VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OUR VERY OWN DAUGHTER OF
CALIFORNIA. KAMALA HARRIS. THE
DAYS AHEAD FOR US AS A STATE
AND FOR OUR NATION WILL BE
CHALLENGING AS WE MAKE OUR WAY
THROUGH WHAT WE HOPE IS THE
HOME STRETCH OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS BODY AND THE
DETERMINATION AND COMMITMENT OF
OUR PEOPLE I TRULY BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA WILL EMERGE STRONGER
THAN EVER. THE HOUR OF TWELVE
O'CLOCK HAVING ARRIVED PURSUANT
TO ARTICLE FOUR SECTION THREE
A. OF THE CONSTITUTION THE
SENATE WILL COME TO ORDER. THIS
SENATORS HAVE TAKEN THEIR SEATS
AND TODAY WE HAVE EIGHT MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATORS
BATES MELENDEZ NIELSEN AND
SENATOR SELECT GLAZER LIMON
NEWMAN ROTH AND STERN. PURSUANT
TO SECTION NINETY ONE FIFTY OF
THE GOVERNMENT CODE ERICA
CONTRARIES SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE BETWEEN A RODRIGUEZ IN
TERMS SERGEANTS AT ARMS AND
MATTHEW BURNS MINUTE CLERK ARE
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE PLACES.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND MEMBERS
ELECT PLEASE PRICE WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER BY SENATOR LIKE
LAYERED AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR ELECT BUT SHOW A BOAT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
THE SENATE CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN COULD NOT BE
WITH US IN THE CHAMBERS TODAY
AND SHE SENT THE FOLLOWING
PRAYER. GRACIOUS IN MYSTERIOUS
GOD OF ALL TODAY WE COME INTO
YOUR PRESENCE WITH GRATITUDE
FOR OUR PAST SINCERE PRAYERS
FOR OUR PRESIDENT AND A HOPEFUL
OUTLOOK FOR OUR FUTURE. PEARL
HARBOR DAY OF REMEMBRANCE
REMINDS US OF THOSE WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED THEIR LIVES TO KEEP
US SAFE IN THE PAST. THOSE MANY
LIVES LOST AND THE WITNESS OF
THEIR FAMILIES ALLOWED FOR THE
TRANSFORMATION OF HARSH
CONFLICT INTO FREEDOM AND PEACE
FOR MANY. WE COME TO THIS DAY
HEAVY HEARTED FOR ALL THOSE
AFFLICTED IN BODY OR SPIRIT
BECAUSE OF THE CORONA VIRUS
PANDEMIC. WE ASK YOU TO GRANT
RELIEF TO THE ELDERLY WHO
DEPEND ON THE GENTLENESS AND
KINDNESS OF OTHERS TO CARE FOR
THEM. THE YOUNG WHO FIND
THEMSELVES SEPARATED FROM THEIR
SCHOOL MATES IN LESS THAN IDEAL
LEARNING SITUATIONS. ESSENTIAL
WORKERS IN HEALTHCARE EDUCATION
FOOD PRODUCTION SECURITY WHO
RISK THEIR OWN HEALTH TO MEET
OUR DAILY NEEDS. AND THOSE WHO
ARE LOSING HOPE NOT SEEING HOW
THEY CAN SURVIVE THE SPIRITUAL
AND ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC. GRACIOUS GOD TODAY AS
WE BEGIN THIS SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE. GIVE COMFORT AND
PEACE TO OUR SENATORS AND THEIR
STAFFS AS THEY WORK TO DISCOVER
NEW AND SURPRISING SOLUTIONS TO
MOUNTING CHALLENGES AHEAD. GIVE
THEM POLITICAL COURAGE TO
CREATE LAWS THAT BENEFIT THE
COMMON GOOD. GIVE THEM BROAD
VISION AND HOLY WISDOM TO HELP
THEM PERSEVERE THROUGH DAYS OF
UNCERTAINTY AND STRUGGLE. AND
EACH DAY MAY THEY HEAR YOU
SPEAK WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT IN
THE DEPTHS OF THEIR HEARTS. LR
NOTICED WROTE. DO NOT BE
DISMAYED BY THE BROKENNESS OF
THE WORLD. ALL THINGS BURKE.
AND ALL THINGS CAN BE MENDED
NOT WITH TIME BUT WITH
INTENTION SO GO NOW LOVE
INTENTIONALLY EXTRAVAGANTLY
UNCONDITIONALLY THIS BROKEN
WORLD THE WHITES IN DARKNESS
FOR THE LIKE. THAT IS YOU. A
MAN. YEAH MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME AS WE RECITE THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH HANDSTANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU MAY BE
SEATED. THEY HAD ALREADY NEEDED
TO THE SECRETARY OF THE SENATE
WILL READ THE CERTIFICATE OF
ELECTION OF THE DULY ELECTED
SENATORS. I ALEX VIDEO
SECRETARY OF STATE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HEREBY CERTIFY
THAT ACCORDING TO THE SEMI
OFFICIAL RESULTS PROVIDED TO MY
OFFICE BY COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS AS OF DECEMBER FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY. THE PERSONS
WHOSE NAMES ARE HEREINAFTER SET
FORTH APPEAR TO HAVE RECEIVED
THE PLURALITY OF VOTES IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE STATE SENATE
DISTRICTS AT THE NOVEMBER THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION.
BUT OPPOSITE THEIR RESPECTIVE
NAMES ARE THE STATE SENATE
DISTRICTS FROM WHICH THEY HAVE
AS OF THIS STATE. APPEAR TO
HAVE RECEIVED A PLURALITY OF
THE VOTES AND THE NAMES OF THE
COUNTY OR COUNTIES COMPRISING
OR FORMING A PORTION OF SAID
DISTRICTS WITH THE NAME OF ANY
COUNTY ENTIRELY WITHIN OR
COMPRISING THE DISTRICTS SHOWN
IN CAPITAL LETTERS. RYAN DALLI
FIRST DISTRICT. BILL DODD.
THIRD DISTRICT. SUSAN
TALAMANTES EGGMAN FIFTH
DISTRICT STEVE GLAZER SEVENTH
DISTRICT. NANCY SKINNER. NINTH
DISTRICT SCOTT WIENER ELEVENTH
DISTRICT. JOSH BECKER
THIRTEENTH DISTRICT DAVE
CORTESE FIFTEENTH DISTRICT JOHN
LAYERED. SEVENTEENTH DISTRICT
S. MONIQUE LIMON NINETY
NINETEENTH DISTRICT SCOTT WELL.
TWENTY FIRST DISTRICT ROSALIE
CHAU CHOI BOGUE TWENTY THIRD
DISTRICT. ANTHONY J. PORTANTINO
TWENTY FIFTH DISTRICT HENRY
STERN TWENTY SEVENTH DISTRICT.
JOSH NEWMAN TWENTY NINTH
DISTRICT RICHARD D. ROTH THIRTY
FIRST DISTRICT LENA GONZALEZ
THIRTY THIRD DISTRICT. STEPHEN
CRAIG BRADFORD THIRTY FIFTH
DISTRICT DAVE MEN THIRTY SEVEN
TH DISTRICT TONI ATKINS THIRTY
NINTH DISTRICT IN WITNESS WHERE
OF I HEAR IN TO SET MY HAND AND
AFFIX THE GREAT SEAL OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS FOURTH
DAY OF DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ALEX TO BE A SECRETARY OF STATE.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE OATH OF OFFICE
FOR THE SENATOR LACKS. SENATOR
LACKS PLEASE RISE STEP TO THE
SIDE OF YOUR DESK AND STAY IN
PLACE TO TAKE YOUR OATH OF
OFFICE. THE OATH OF OFFICE WILL
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
HONORABLE MARTIN J. JENKINS
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
MORNING AFTERNOON RATHER- CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OK ALL RIGHT IT IS
CERTAINLY A PLEASURE AND A
PRIVILEGE FOR ME TO BE PRESENT
WITH YOU TO ADMINISTER THE OATH
OF OFFICE THAT YOU WERE ABOUT
TO UNDERTAKE. EXTEND A HEARTY
CONGRATULATIONS FROM- CHIEF
JUSTICE CANTIL CYCLEWAY. TO
ALLOW ME TO BE HERE IN HER
STATE THIS MORNING AND FROM
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED JUDGES AND
JUSTICES A LARGE JUDICIARY IN
THE WORLD. THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHER WHO SEND THEIR
HEARTFELT CONGRATULATIONS AS
WELL. BEFORE I ADMINISTER THE
OATH. I WANT TO SAY JUST A
COUPLE OF THINGS. IF YOUR
ELECTION COMES AT A SIGNIFICANT
TIME IN OUR COUNTRY IS JUST
BEEN STATED. DAILY PRESS
REPORTS REFLECT MUCH RANCOR AND
DIVISION IN OUR RANKS. IT IS
ALSO TRUE YOUR GOVERNANCE WILL
BE COMPLICATED. BY THE RAGING
PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH THE LAST NINE MONTHS. BUT
I KNOW WE HAVE A SECRET WEAPON
IN THIS COUNTRY. I AM A WITNESS
TO. IT IS CALLED THE RULE OF
LAW. IT IS OUR NORTH STAR. THAT
LEADS US SAFELY HOME. ALWAYS
LEAVE THE SIGNAL. THAT WAS MADE
CLEAR TO ME AS SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW I WAS A FEDERAL JUDGE IN
ANOTHER LIFE FOR ABOUT ELEVEN
YEARS. AND AT A CONFIRMATION
HEARING IN THE EVERITT DIRKSEN
ROOM THERE IN THE CAPITAL. AND
AS I WAS CALLED TO THE FRONT.
TO THE QUESTION. SENATOR
FEINSTEIN WAS EXTOLLING MY
VIRTUES. MADE HIM SHE PROBABLY
MADE UP. I HAD A CHANCE TO TURN
AROUND. AND CATCH A GLIMPSE OF
MY FATHER. IT WAS A FARMER AND
BROOKSHIRE TEXAS. REFORM PASSED.
THE FIRST TIME I EVER SAW THAT
MANCROFT. IT WAS CLEAR TO ME
ALL AT ONCE. WHAT HE SHOULD
BILLS TO USE. BECAUSE IN THAT
MOMENT. HE COULDN'T IMAGINE
THAT OUR SON OF HIS. WOULD
BECOME THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THIRD AFRICAN AMERICAN. TO
SERVE ON THE FEDERAL BENCH. HOW
COULD SUCH A THING HAPPENED. IT
HAPPENED BECAUSE THE RULE OF
LAW. THE FALL OF PLASTIC. THE
RISE OF BROWN. LET TO MY
NOMINATION AND CONFIRMATION. SO
WHAT BAD. I WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS. BESIDES
SOBERLY. WITH A HARD. SO IF YOU
PLEASE RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND.
AND REPEAT AFTER ME. HI AND
STATE YOUR NAME I. DO SOLEMNLY
SWEAR OR AFFIRM. THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES. BOTH
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC. THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES. AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY. WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION. OR PURPOSE
OF EVASION FOR. AND I WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY. DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES. UPON WHICH I'M ABOUT TO
ENTER. CONGRATULATIONS SEN.
THANK YOU JUST A SECOND FOR THE
INSPIRING WORDS AND
CONGRATULATIONS EVERYONE
SENATORS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SENATORS SELECT CHORE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND
ADMINISTERED THEIR OATH OF
OFFICE ONE AT A TIME SENATOR
ELECT GLAZER BOTH OF OFFICE BY
JUDGE SCOTT PATTON. ALL RIGHT
TO BE HEARD. OKAY CAN YOU HEAR.
YES YES. HI STEPHEN EMBRASURE I
STEVEN M. GLAZER DO SOLEMNLY
SWEAR YOU SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT I
WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND I WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE THAT I WILL BEAR
TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY THAT I TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION OR PURPOSE
OF EVASION AND THEN I WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES AND I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE THE DUTIES.
UPON WHICH I ABOUT TO. UPON
WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENSURE.
THANK YOU OKAY. SENATOR LIKELY
MONNING BOTH OF OFFICE BY JUDGE
RAIMUNDO MONTEZ TO POLKA. WELL
DONE. VERY GOOD. THIS THE OTHER
ONE TWO ZERO ONE RIGHT. REPEAT
AFTER ME. HI MONICA I MONIQUE
LIMON SONGS OR AFFIRM DO YOU
SOLEMNLY SWEAR AND AFFIRM THAT
I WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES IS THAT I WILL SUPPORT
AND DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES NUMBER OF.
HELLO FOR. AND THE- OF THE
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. VERY TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES NUMBER.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT I TAKE THIS
OBLIGATIONFREELY. TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION OR PURPOSE
OF EVASION BUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION AND THAT I WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE. AND I
WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I AM ABOUT. THE DUTIES THAT
WENT ON WHICH I AM ABOUT TO
ENTER. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS SENATE RESOLUTION
ONE BY SENATOR RUBIO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. SENATE RESOLUTION
ONE BY SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE
TO HOLD OVER SENATORS. SENATOR
RUBIO YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
S. R. ONE THIS RESOLUTION
ALLOWED SENATORS TO TAKE THE
OATH OF OFFICE AND I URGE AND I
BILLS THANK YOU. SENATOR RUBIO
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ALL THIS
INFO OF ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
THE RESOLUTION STAY ONLINE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES
HAVE THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. SENATORS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. THE
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL OF
ALL SENATORS. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BAKER. GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY DODD
DURAZO EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROWTH
HERTZBERG HUESO. HER TADO JONES
LAYERED LEYVA. MCGUIRE MAN BUT
CHAU AGO. PAN PORTANTINO RUBIO.
SKINNER FEINBERG WHITE HOUSE
SKI. WIENER WELL. THANK YOU THE
NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE RESOLUTION TWO BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. SENATE RESOLUTION
TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
RELATIVE TO THE ELECTION OF
OFFICERS. CENTER HERTZBERG YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM WE CAN THE GOVERNOR AND
PRESIDENT OF THIS. IT IS WITH
GREAT PRIDE CONFIDENCE AND
OPTIMISM THAT I RISE TO PRESENT
TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WEATHER
HERE IN PERSON OR PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY AS WELL AS TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS WATCHING
US HERE TODAY FAR AND WIDE. WE
SENATE RESOLUTION TO WHICH
DESIGNATES THE OFFICERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SESSION. UNDER OUR OWN
SENATE RULE TEN POINT FIVE THE
SENATE HAS THE AUTHORITY WHICH
I HAVE TO BE OFF A PRICE TODAY.
TO ELECT THE SENATE APPROACH TO
A PRESIDENT PRO TEM SECRETARY
OF THE SENATE AND SERGEANT ARMS.
THIS VOTE TODAY I PROJECT WILL
MAKE HISTORY. AS WE ELECTED ALL
FEMALE TEAM OF OFFICERS TO LEAD
US HERE IN THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. WE WILL ALSO MAKE
HISTORY. AS WE GOVERN DURING
THESE MOST CHALLENGING TIMES.
IN MORE THAN A CENTURY THIS
TEAM WILL HELP LEAD US AS WE
START THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION
GAINES EXTRAORDINARY TIMES AS
JUSTICE JENKINS MOST ELOQUENTLY
REFERRED TO IN HIS COMMENTS. SR
TWO WOULD ELECT THE INCREDIBLE
SENATOR TONI G. ATKINS OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE SENATE.
V. UNBELIEVABLY HARD WORKING
DIRECTLY CONTROLS FROM THE
GREAT SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AS
OUR SECRETARY OF THE SENATE.
AND A VERY TALENTED EXPERIENCES
EXPERIENCE KATRINA RODRIGUEZ AS
OUR SERGEANT AT ARMS OF THE
SENATE. OUR OFFICERS FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO REGULAR SESSION. I ASK FOR
EVERYONE'S AYE VOTE ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
SENATOR HERTZBERG REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
THE RESOLUTION SAY I'D- HEY ALL
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. THE OATH OF OFFICE
WILL NOW BE ADMINISTERED TO THE
NEWLY ELECTED OFFICERS OF THE
SENATE BY THE HONORABLE MARTIN
J. JENKINS ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
WILL PRO TEM ACTIONS PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM PLEASE RAISE YOUR RIGHT
HAND. AND REPEAT AFTER ME HI
AND STATION. TWO SEVENTY SQUARE.
THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION. WORKING OF
THE UNITED STATES. AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. GREAT STATE.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE AND I WILL
BEAR TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE
TO THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL REST
RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION OR PURPOSE OF EVASION
AND I WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE. WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I'M ABOUT TO IN THE DUTIES UPON
WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENTER
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU. IT
IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE THE
HONORABLE TONI G. ATKINS OF SAN
DIEGO.
OKAY A RETURNING
COLLEAGUES WELCOME BACK. I WANT
TO THANK THE PEOPLE OF THE
THIRTY NINTH SENATE DISTRICT
FOR PUTTING THEIR FAITH IN ME
ONCE AGAIN AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU MY COLLEAGUES AND MY
FRIENDS FOR TRUSTING ME TO
CONTINUE SERVING AS PRESIDENT
PRO TEM. LET ME ADD MY THANKS
TO OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE. AND TO
OUR CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE MARTIN JENKINS. YOU
BOTH ONEROUS WITH YOUR PRESENCE
HERE IN THE SENATE TODAY AND WE
THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO ORGANIZE
THE SENATE FOR THE COMING YEAR
IT IS NECESSARY FOR US TO HAVE
A PHYSICAL QUORUM TODAY HERE ON
THE FLOOR. SO HERE WE ARE. TO
PERFORM THE ESSENTIAL TASK OF
SWEARING IN SENATORS AND
ELECTING OUR. ENDING SECRETARY
OF THE SENATE ERICA CONTRARIUS
ARE BRAND NEW LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL KEROGEN KIDS. AND I'M
DELIGHTED TO ADD VOTING TO MAKE
OUR INTERIM CHIEF KATRINA
REPAIR CHRIS OUR NEW CHIEF
SERGEANT AT ARMS THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS. WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THESE OUTSTANDING
WOMEN I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE FORGIVE ME
BERNIE. BUT I'M GOING TO DO IT
TO RECOGNIZE BERNADETTE MCNULTY
OUR CHIEF ASSISTANT SECRETARY
OF THE SENATE. DURING THE
INTERIM BERNIE RECEIVE THE
TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE STAFF
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FROM THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF LEGISLATIVE
CLERKS AND SECRETARIES. I
ABSOLUTELY HAD TO RECOGNIZE HER
THE SOONEST THAT WE POSSIBLY
COULD BE BACK TOGETHER. AND YOU
ARE OF COURSE AWARE OF ALL OF
THE PRECAUTIONS THE SENATE HAS
TAKEN TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
SENATORS OF OUR STAFF AND
VISITORS TO THE CAPITAL. AND
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY CHANGED OUR
DOING SWEARING IN DAY AND
THAT'S OKAY. WHEN OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE DELAYING
WEDDINGS AND GRADUATIONS AND
OTHER IMPORTANT LIFE EVENTS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
UNDERSTANDS. AND WILL GLADLY
TAKE A PASS ON SOME OF THE POP
IN CIRCUMSTANCE. THAT WE WOULD
NORMALLY ENJOY. IN THE COMING
YEAR THE SENATE WILL CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON COVE IN NINETEEN ON
ECONOMIC RELIEF AND RECOVERY.
AND ON ADDRESSING CHRONIC
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THIS CRISIS. TO
THAT END I AM PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SOME OF THE VERY
FIRST BILLS INTRODUCED TODAY
WILL BE THE SENATE HOUSING
PACKAGE. AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS
BEEN A CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY FOR YEARS AND IT'S
BEEN MADE EVEN WORSE IN EVERY
PART OF OUR STATE BYCHKOVA
NINETEEN. SO HOUSING WILL BE
BACK EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
WILDFIRE RESPONSE WILL BE BACK.
EFFORTS TO END THE HARM OF FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS OF SYSTEMIC
RACISM WILL BE BACK. BROADBAND
ACCESS WILL BE BACK. SO NO
KIDDING CALIFORNIA HAS TO DO
THEIR HOMEWORK. AND A TACO BELL
PARKING LOT. I'M ALSO SURE YOUR
DISTRICT OFFICES HAVE BEEN AS
BUSY AS MINE. HELPING
CALIFORNIANS NAVIGATE DELAYS
AND UNCERTAINTIES AT EDT. WE
WILL CONTINUE DELIVERING FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO EXAMINE HOW THEIR
EXPERIENCE CAN BE IMPROVED AND
NOT JUST IN TIMES OF CRISIS.
WHEN I WOKE THIS MORNING I
COULDN'T HELP THINKING ABOUT MY
FRIEND ALBERT IN A LOS AL WAS A
MUSICIAN. HE WAS ALSO IN THE
ARMY STATIONED IN HAWAII IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE. OUR WAS ON
HIS WAY BACK TO THE BASE WHEN
THE FIRST ATTACK AT PEARL
HARBOR SEVENTY NINE YEARS AGO
TODAY. HE SAID YOU COULD SEE
THE PILOTS FACES. HE SPENT THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS WITHOUT
SLEEP RELAYING MESSAGES BETWEEN
OFFICERS AND AIRFIELDS ON HIS
MOTORCYCLE. I CAN'T HELP BUT
INTERJECT RIGHT HERE THAT TODAY
IN THIS CHAMBER. WE HAVE SEVEN
MEMBERS OF THE ARMED FORCES WHO
SERVED US AS VETERANS HERE
TODAY SEVEN. THE HIGHEST NUMBER
IN DECADES THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER AND I WERE DISCUSSING
THAT AND SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE IN THE
SENATE HAVE A CAUCUS OF OUR
OWN. VETERANS ODD TO REALLY
COMMEMORATE THIS DAY. I KNOW
THAT BOTH THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
IN IRAN CREDIBLY PROUD OF THAT
FACT. SO ON THIS DAY DECEMBER
SEVENTH I WAS THINKING ABOUT AL
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
GREATEST GENERATION AND THE
SACRIFICES THAT THEY MADE BOTH
OVERSEAS AND HERE AT HOME. THEY
MAY DO WITH RATIONED FOOD GAS
AND TIRES THEY SAY GREASE AND
FOOD SCRAPS AND THEY LED
NEIGHBORHOOD DRAWS TO COLLECT
PAPER TEN AND OTHER MATERIALS.
THEY ALSO BUILD QUALITY
EMERGENCY HOUSING TO TAKE CARE
OF THE WORKERS NEEDED FOR THE
WAR EFFORT. AND THEY PROVIDED
CHILD CARE AND OTHER VITAL
SERVICES TO HELP ALL THE ROSIE
THE RIVETERS WHO IT ENTERED THE
WORK FORCE. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT WE'RE BEING ASKED TO DO
TODAY TO WEAR MASKS TO AVOID
LARGE GROUPS. TO STAY CLOSE TO
HOME. THAT'S NOT A LOT TO ASK
COMPARE TO THE SACRIFICES
OTHERS HAVE MADE FOR THE
GREATER GOOD. AND IT IS NOT A
LOT FOR CALIFORNIANS TO ASK
THAT WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN AS
LEGISLATORS AND AS INDIVIDUALS
TO READ KATE THE SIX CENTRAL
THREAT TO OUR LOVED ONES OUR
COMMUNITIES. ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND OUR ECONOMY. WE
OWE IT TO EACH OTHER TO THOSE
WHO CAME BEFORE US AND THOSE
WHO WILL COME AFTER US TO MEET
THESE TOUGH TIMES WITH THE SAME
KIND OF COURAGE SACRIFICE AND
DETERMINATION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DISPLAYED SO MANY TIMES. THERE
IS MUCH THAT MUST BE DONE AND I
BELIEVE WE WILL DO IT. THERE
WILL ALSO BE MUCH TO CELEBRATE
ESPECIALLY THIS TIME OF YEAR.
PLEASE KNOW THAT MY SPOUSE
JENNIFER AND I WISH ALL OF YOU
AND YOURS THE HAPPIEST OF
HOLIDAYS AND A PRODUCTIVE
REWARDING. AND BORING. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'D LIKE NOW TO
INVITE OUR SENATE REPUBLICAN
LEADER FROM THE GREAT CITY OF
BAKERSFIELD AND MY FRIEND.
SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER
SHANNON GROVE TO MAKE SOME
REMARKS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM. FIRST TODAY IS PEARL
HARBOR DAY SO WE NEED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO PRAY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO SAY A PRAYER FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
SERVED AS THE GREATEST
GENERATIONTHAT ANSWERED THE
CALL TO ENSURE THE SURVIVAL OF
THE GREATEST NATION ON EARTH.
TODAY IS ALSO THE TIME THAT WE
COME TOGETHER TO WELCOME OUR
NEW SENATORS TO THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE. THIS NEW LEGISLATURE
THIS THIS THE LEGISLATURE JOINS
THE RANKS OF ONLY FOUR THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS. WHO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
ON BEHALF OF THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
STATE'S NEWEST PUBLIC SERVANTS
TO THE STATE CAPITOL. SERVING
AS A SENATOR IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS BOTH AN HONOR
AND AN EVEN AND HAD AN IMMENSE
RESPONSIBILITY. YOU ARE AMONG A
SMALL GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS.
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SERVE IN
THIS BUILDING ON THE RED CARPET
IN IN HISTORY. YOU HAVE BEEN
ELECTED BY OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
SERVE AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
THIS IS A IMMENSE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT YOU TAKE
HERE TODAY. THE LAST NINE
MONTHS HAVE BROUGHT MANY
CHALLENGES TO THIS STATE OUR
BUSINESSES AND THE FORTY
MILLION RABBIT RESIDENTS THAT
CALL THE GOLDEN STATE HOME. THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE ARE HURTING
AND WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS RESPONSIBLY.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO HELP MOVE
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND SETTING THE
TONE OF THIS BODY THAT WE MAY
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER. I
PRAY WE CAN ALL COME TOGETHER
IN THIS NEW LEGISLATIVE SESSION
TO SERVE THE PURPOSE THAT WE
WERE GIVEN BY ARTICLE FOUR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. AS
IT READS THE LEGISLATIVE POWER
OF THE STATE IS VESTED IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
BEFORE US TODAY WE HAVE PART OF
THAT LEGISLATIVE BODY RIGHT IN
THIS BUILDING THAT MAKES UP
PART OF THE- PART OF US HERE
THAT MAKE UP THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. LEGISLATIVE
SESSION IT'S A GREAT CHALLENGE
TO WORK ALONGSIDE EACH OTHER
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE GOVERNOR
AS WE NAVIGATE UNCHARTERED
TERRITORY. IN WORDS IN THE
WORDS OF PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN. I'D LIKE TO QUOTE. I
KNOW IT'S A HELL OF A CHALLENGE
BUT ASK YOURSELVES IF NOT US
WHO AND IF NOT NOW WHEN. MAY
GOD GIVE US WISDOM AND
DIRECTION AS WE SEEK TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF ALL OF THOSE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE EXPECTING
US TO ACT TO RESTORE GOLDEN
STATE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THINK
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR CAN LOCK US-FOR JOINING US TODAY AND FOR
HER REMARKS. BEFORE WE MOVE TO
A MORE BUSINESS WE NEED TO
ADMINISTER THE OATH OF OFFICE
OFFICE FOR OUR SECRETARY IN OUR
CHIEF SERGEANT SO LET'S DO THAT
NOW AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT. SO
WHEN YOU BOTH PLEASE RAISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND. AND WE'LL START
WITH YOU SECRETARY. AND THEN
YOU. I STATE YOUR NAME. IT US
DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR D. SALINAS
FOR THREE HOURS OF AND DEFEND
THE CLASS OF THE STATES. THE
FANS THAT I WILL SUPPORT DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE. IN THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC FOREIGN
AND DOMESTIC THAT I WILL BEAR
TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
AND I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION OR PURPOSE OF EVASION
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE AND I WILL
WELL AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE
THE DUTIES UPON WHICH I'M ABOUT
TO ENTER. THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I AM. CONGRATULATES. S. H.
EVERYTHING TO SELL ME SWEAR.
BUT I SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE.
BECAUSE OF THE UNITED STATES
THEY AND CONSTITUTION THE STATE.
I ALL ENEMIES. FOREIGN DOMESTIC.
THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE AND- TO
THE CLASS I MEAN STATES.
AMBICOM OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT I TAKE SAMAN
FOR. APPLICATION WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL. FOR OF EVASION. AND A
WELFARE JUST CHAU. NUMBER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. WITH. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG RELATIVE TO THE
SELECTION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. CENTER
OF BURKE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I'M PLEASED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE WHICH
SELECTS CARA JENKINS AS OUR
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW ALLEGE
COUNCIL PROVIDES INDIVIDUAL AND
COLLECTIVE ADVICE TO US AS
LEGISLATORS ON LEGISLATIVE
MATTERS THEY'RE HIGHLY
COMPETENT VERY HARD WORKING
EXTREMELY DEDICATED. AND THEY
PROVIDE OBJECTIVE ADVICE
SOMETIMES TO OBJECTIVE ADVICE
BUT THEY PROVIDE OBJECTIVE
ADVICE. WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE
THAT MISS JENKINS IS GOING TO
BE OUR LEDGE COUNCIL
RESPONSIBLE LEGISLATIVECOUNCIL
UNIT- MANY YOU KNOW MISS
JENKINS FROM YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE- ILITCH COUNSEL'S
OFFICE SHE'S BEEN A DEPUTY FOR
OVER TEN YEARS. SHE IS
TALENTED- ORGANIZED WHEN
DEALING WITH PEOPLE'S WORK IN
PATIENTS WITH ALL OF US BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE-
MISS JENKINS GRADUATED FROM
MCGEORGE LAW SCHOOL AND HOLDS
AN UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE FROM UC
SANTA BARBARA. SHE HAS THE FULL
SUPPORT OVER SUPPORT SPOUSE
TROY IN ALSO OF SOPHIE ROCKSON
IN REMEDY FOR THREE DOGS VERY
IMPORTANT- WE WHICH WE THINK
SHE'S GOING TO DO AN
OUTSTANDING JOB FOR THE PEOPLE
SITTING CALIFORNIA AND FOR US
SO CONGRATULATIONS TO MISS
JENKINS AND HER. FAMILY AND I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER AMBERG MEMBERS THIS
RESULT READ REQUIRES TO ONE BUT
TO BE A- MEADOW SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I.
ARCHULETA. FIVE ATKINS AYE
BAKER. FIVE FORGES. FIVE
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI
COURTESY I DALY. I DODD I TO
RAZA. I EGGMAN FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I HUESO. I
HER TADO FIVE JONES. I LAYERED.
I LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE. FIVE
MILLION. BY A SHOW OF BOTH. I
PAN I PORTANTINO FIVE RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER FIVE AMBERG I Y.
CASKEY. FIVE WIENER AYE WILK I
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY WILL
NOW GO TO OUR MEMBERS REPEAT
THE REPEAT OF JOINING HAS
REMOTELY OF MEMBERS WHO ARE
JOINING US REMOTELY WHEN WE GO
TO YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
WHAT YOU'RE VOTING ON WHICH IS
RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE AND HOW
YOU WERE VOTING. MADAM
SECRETARY. BATES SENATOR BATES
FINE US SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE HI BATES
FIVE. GLAZER SENATORS STEVE
GLAZER ON SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE HI GLAZER
HI. LIMóN SENATOR LEE KNOWN ON
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE HI LIMóN HI MELENDEZ.
WINDOWS SEVEN S. C. R. ONE ALL
RIGHT MELENDEZ FIVE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN S. CI VOTING HI. S. CI
ONE. THIS S. ZERO ONE MAN IS
THE ARE CAN RESTATE THAT CENTER
NIELSEN S. R. ONE S. C. R. ONE
PERFECT THANK YOU. NIELSEN I.
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO. THIRTY SIX
EXCUSE ME I'VE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES AND THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
IF THERE IS NO FURTHER ITEM
BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE
SEEING NONE MADAM PRO TEM THE
DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- TO MY
COLLEAGUES- CONGRATULATIONS BE
SAFE BE WELL THE BEST OF
HOLIDAYS TO YOU AND YOUR
FAMILIES. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY
JANUARY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT TWO PM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THE DISCLOSURE MAIN OPEN
UNTIL THE HOUR OF THREE THIRTY
PM FOR THE INTRODUCTION OF
BILLS THE SENATE WILL STAND IN
RECESS UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT.
TWO PM THE SENATE IS NOW. IN
RECESS AS A REMINDER THE DEATH
WILL REMAIN OPEN FOR BILL
INTRODUCTION DURING THE MONTH
OF DECEMBER THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS.